[Music]
laughing Lisa Gonzales your sonic
imagine Alec Oh
anyway you might all these young
soldiers I'm talking about roses in the
motionless cuddly what is the body
veggies woman yeah what are the
reactions I pretty much just exhale your
reaction to inside from this temple of
Lisa player okay so what we'll have
these bubbles would we actually summer
are you that video ring yeah what were
some charities and she didn't show up
you know some she our team what you did
like the others this is supposed a
whisper Timpanogos no control initiation
Cameron hacer el our initial Lucy
Ferrier whoa
you know one thing I wanted to ask is
why do they okay the go Illuminati
stupido the way I stopped pretty much
anybody lays it out and it our sort of
the regional feel a little message
what's your understanding you know this
is you know that's what only samosas yes
hahaha well there's the right side the
wrong side in the discrete the three
sites Illuminati confession is it why do
they have the cross all the way around
have you noted that you know what it is
I did auntie like opposite of everything
oh this is happening yeah CJ receipt
okay finally attend Rhea comb ejército
editor knows Jenna
music opera entrevista royal para ser un
ritual danisha struction grand a
conclusive invert ears see potent movs
deaf whereas a vessel in Dario cerrado e
totalmente privado y para ser una
iglesia no a mucho la Bienvenue a
pseudovector so measure Elsa frozen
regale sister blonde a Giga Sutra narrow
Sunnah Barca estamos dando de que se
trata todas Pedro por si la no tenemos
judas Kodo un katanas ray 10 am well
across in ver que de ella school creo
que para nosotros la que digo TCH a so a
los guachos casanetti da de da de
Infante speciality todo MOBA Oh devil
engines Cristiano general solo release
Toria pork represent a porn granny in
ganó el que no se any dope or Lucifer
ego represent a mere my tier VI el mal
que una noche para nosotros a echo por
todo su yo como lo vas a hacer lo bien
posso via meant a perch a Vienna VA peg
went a super Kimiko okay so I see nephew
Daedalus a fake Ana's addendum living
Evo Evo to go do a BOGO class descend a
few odd no kusenov a toda a minha for
example odubajo de bez Monsieur de
Schengen novo ma hosted as me pablo
escobar yahi desde hoy con este domingo
de buzos
nosotros a loco si Fergie nose no cream
o ZN l mark omo alko sooo fun Casey
assessed rose mallow que tener sexo
Pardo
Wow salutations organizer is not much if
I say yes it's okay
it's not bad I mean I've seen Islam into
worse if you know it's more it's worth
of a sin to do it in your neighbor okay
hi
Lamia cala quiero que la gente que
problema con given day market a Muslim
America yo solo from your account o
segundo say a mirror while the purpose
of the whole movie el momento que pasa
por ninguna otra cosa nostra Sierra
enviado por Niva man's affairs Mooji ah
dough for a refund Rivera narara
adorable
Horacio just show you who receive in
super day no defender gomes pedrosa give
me a strict Oh Ali Lucia fen entró Trask
hace mucho que el tipo que entra Nuria
on rio del mundo y lo que unos ma look
don't dismiss cleanses gone around Oh
would be a poet a see du haut de todos
juntos embellish a Craig Johannes
verdere salvage a casado you scar no oto
says respuestas came Karan
muy bien Oh del mundo yonago como puede
que Musa Moreno turn arrow
just basically say off the squad doesn't
answer I will buy him any money but
isn't it scary how easily people can do
that laughs what everyone's got their
problems
yeah but it's a little exploration
because I think I would say Africa
missionary do this question later is
this they'll give them something about
Jesus cages this is from Jesus Jesus God
yes so it shows that it would be honest
with me I think it shows a with their
religion is that they have to sell it to
people
oh no they sell it like we look like
give them money to buy the religion uno
es casi la noche no devil demos a la
finca Victor Damian Peregrine accion cos
a ver que tan lejos o circus tamos Debu
tipo de manifestation Cape you Derrick
on Sierra's say con una religion say
estamos a Punto entrar la initiation
camión hacer en la religion Lucifer inna
Victor damiana expect on teh pero lo que
sus empuja expect on teófilo see de
Carvajal oh so Troma Tunica [ __ ] an
upon Tony paster may investor may
enlarge Sheehan OC Farina
entonces que vemos cape and a perfecto
para nada meant a TR Moya Nardo nombre
no Subaru's yo cheap enemas music
assalaamu e que en el nombre del Oso
pious hair Sergio's Altos Atomos
so Aaron Gary just coat Madison Common
versus rusev Abuja Sabo coat yo no
reason Jose Pankaj Udhas in Autocode
Umberto
toyou Sara Dora por ahora como se hey
cordial mint a sacar el Estadio
hey de la tierra return otário aunt
Ettie no Caesar tom bray Aurelio Soho
avoiding occu - Dahlia with palm on the
hands of all is Jennifer el universo
pawn Seto tenemos este hombre on 20p
endo 40 you don't have such a made-up
like version if you'd open up the oven
like this
what is only another night ahead playing
some good
okay look how come you know me I'm
kapeniak under D producer Jeremy of Todd
Burpo for loss Lucy's life or roselucia
tell Universal Desilu knows yet earlier
Todd delivered on here de Namur theorem
or the other projects yourself or near
the direction yeah hilarious man 139
wanted a key Spanish it's in Spanish
entertaining and calmness buscando is
Carlo the Camino Camino 3 J M again
Shetty something so you know the bit
where he was repeating after many
bullshitting say Tonya how did you guys
see you inside as it is addressing I
should have loved Bob really really a
little bit funny when you feel kind of
sorry from the uniform you're not come
on yet now I'm going to share so you
guys day ok this is the story of a
scholar ok he's teaching these students
yeah and they go through a book of toe
heat yeah so the oneness of Allah etc
and this teacher is teaching them for a
while yeah like for time so these
students are getting bored really like
look who's done this book really like to
move on to something else so he values
total Toby Toby Toby tour the waters of
Allah is that for anyone
okay so so what happened is this a
magisterial profound and it's a big
lesson for all of us and those who are
watching so he says ok we will we're
gonna move on next weekend okay
so the following May they come and what
does it is like and like guys you know a
story one really really strange Sonia
and he's like my Portuguese have you
know that house over there to say yet
he's like I heard that they sacrifice
chickens in the name of another deity so
they were like oh no no no really that's
so they had a reaction to it
yeah okay so there was a sec Wow okay
they were shocked they were shocked
there and this day one so they had
another process
and the following day the chef I study
said look did you guys hear in that
house there was a man and a safe in his
mother so they will have you what are
you like they went on a mud one Lance
Network chef are you serious let's go on
that burn the house now let's go kill
them all here like mr. baza here and
then the teacher turned him and said you
won't need to stop teaching to eat
you haven't even understood to eat
because the fact that you had a reaction
to a house which a person would have
attention to another mother which is
disgusting
yeah which is disgusting yeah and we
know at least look there was a river
list of ugly inaudible one of the
narrations if I'm not mistaken is that a
person who's involved in river one form
of river it's worse than having social
intercourse with a mummy the cabin and
look bro he said the reason one of them
stopped teaching tawheed is when I said
to you guys in that house in that house
there is that individuals cutting in the
name of another deity you guys isn't as
short as use to the house so it shows
you understand Sahib and [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
is the most filthiest most disgusting
thing on the stomach then as we feel and
the moment we don't realize the missile
remains it to me first as well the
moment that we don't realize is we don't
understand what risk exactly we don't
understand how disgusting how filthy how
like one lies the biggest sin I used to
do understand it now we're not deleting
others by talking murder on this wrong
but in Islam as your shift is like next
I would like the fact that when I watch
that and after I was up ok I'm actually
laughing at the stay that they're doing
that but actually I should be more
disgusted then if he was watch a video
of a mother and son have a different
score there the fact that what it shows
is Lawrence is that we'd be little when
this a sin a wrongdoing run towards our
life like eyes okay when we see
something when something abnormal like
infants happening we have this discussed
that we wanna vomit or is it you get it
it shows us that we don't understand to
read properly and how disgusting [ __ ]
gives and obviously we're laughing not
because what they're doing is calm but
in this instance is because we're like
you guys idiot you don't translate in
that instance
and to be honest guys also right now one
thing guys want to finish off with is
these words I've started design side of
it so the Angels proceed with our smart
aleck we could Adam Alisa Lamia so all
the Angels prostrated analysis all so
all the Angels prostrate all of them
entirely except Iblees he was arrogant
and became among the disbelievers yes
Allah said o it please what prevented
you from prostrating to to that which I
created with my hands
where were you arrogant or were you
among the whole team at a hotel mini
burger transgresses he said I am better
than him
you created me from fire and created him
from clay Allah said then go out of
paradise for indeed you were expelled
one of the cursed and India from you is
my curse on to the day of judgment he
sent my lord then replied replies me
until the day they are resurrected look
Alex on his panel your fun you have a
value of Allah and your disobeys Allah
and your asking permission of allah tala
abnormal answer that is you get it look
at this video that you're in but you're
asking Allah what is next
Allah said so indeed you are those who
are deprived under the day off until the
time of the well-known year and he said
look at it I love the champagne
oh Allah by your might I will surely
mislead them oh can you just confirm in
this very moment in Allah I swear by
your own and your might down the
misguided
now look at your life to me is a dream
except among them your chosen servants
yeah etc etc so you can we can see from
this video action dream chance a
wonderful thing a liberal yet just go
back a couple of a subtle when they
start referring to all the angels and
yes touch upon that because I know a lot
of people believe that is not a fallen
angel in good point now what we believe
we don't believe is a fallen angel do
you ever try to say yeah what we believe
is that now some people say oh god my
second is he an angel though because
Allah says here look among the Angels
the other organs prostrate yeah but she
sounded we don't blue Shaitaan is an
angel yes we believe these belong to the
jinn time here however he sees his hands
background he was so much he would
worship Allah yeah is that he was at
that level a key that he was class among
the Angels yes could induce leo
you know what's it they obey so what was
he in it he was amongst that living and
look where he dropped to so we don't
believe that he's a fallen angel he's
not injured in the beginning didn't save
us Christianity or maybe too bad
mentioned it's one of these limits
something yes I don't blame them because
they're going from one madness or shape
of version of Jesus to another yeah
because the Shaitaan is quoting them to
worship Jesus and now this is going they
won't damage the world Shaitaan alone
but yeah that's about it shows you at
this one our life the levels that people
are going to you know and yeah that's my
any other last moments before it was
quiet is fun Allah is it having coffee
later it's a very good point yes very
good point yeah stay away from shook
yeah that's why Paul says hope you guys
benefited just make the video series and
everything like yeah Oh what time is
good come here electricity anyway that
sounds for watching are some like what
about hedges we're gonna have more we
actually there's some funny ones or
people being kidnapped in cars not funny
no but widening kidnapped and also the
person they kidnap are they happy with
the kidnapped I mean even kidnapped with
this happy we could never find us in
Charlene Cara Kristen over the past was
a cool
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo chu man and man
another shoe shoe
hey give me one I'm sorry
subscribe
[Music]